For the people that are
trying to build,
they're coming into the industry,
they don't really know
what they're doing just yet.
What's some words of advice
you would give them,
how to break into crypto
like you did?
Find a community.
I gave this advice
to so many people.
I've seen so many
success stories from people
starting from just being
part of a community
to becoming CEOs.
I've seen this story
so many times.
We've hired so many people
of the early DeFi contributors
that were just interested
in the protocol.
So you just message
the founder, hey,
you know, I want to
contribute. I can do this,
this and that.
People will respond to you.
It's literally how it goes.
That was literally my story.